and okay i could tell you the stats in  the u.s it's like 85 percent of black  men um date in their race but it go ups  to 30 percent date out when they make  over a certain amount of money yeah that  sounds about right you see them at nfl  stars yeah yeah so it's like if they  make a certain amount of money it ups to  30 why do you think that is well to me  it's like because um in the u.s at least  i i have no idea what the stats are here  but i think when men get money they want  a pretty little skinny thing and like  they want they want the hot chick and  and statistically black women in the us  are more obese than other races  so like to me it's just more of them  aren't in shape you don't think it's a  racing you think it might be a shape  thing  [Music]